[Musique]
là c'est difficile de définir un surdoué
en tout cas ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
être surdoué
c'est d'une certaine façon avoir une
forme d'intelligence qui va fonctionner
un peu différemment
[Musique]
un surdoué il a une façon d'être au
monde qui est toujours très intense des
grandes envies des grands besoins de
transformer l'environnement de faire
bouger les choses c'est cette capacité à
pouvoir sauver le monde j'ai envie de
dire à être en quête de sens à faire
quelque chose d'utile
[Musique]
déjà ce qui est important c'est qu'on ne
mesure pas l'intelligence ce qu'on
évalue c'est ce qu'est capable de
produire l'intelligence dans un contexte
donné
[Musique]
il existe qu'un test de qi qui du coup
est un peu réducteur pas mal réducteur
puisqu'on va tester sur touba quoi
l'intelligence linguistique et encore
une fois mathématiques spatiale est un
peu relationnel
mais il faudrait vraiment qu'il ya un
petit plus moderne des tests de qi ça
prend en compte aussi le la l'émotivité
le stress la personnalité c'est à dire
que c'est pas juste un score c'est pour
ça que c'est essentiel que ce soit fait
par un psychologue et qu'on peut pas
calculer son cul et sur internet
mais de toute façon il n'est pas
nécessaire d'avoir un centre en la
moyens décents pour se sentir surdoué il
n'est pas nécessaire non plus de
dépenses et 450 euros dans un test pour
faire pour voir son et surdoué ou pas de
toute façon il ya des caractéristiques
[Musique]
le surdoué ne fera pas les choses parce
qu'il faut les faire il les fera si ça a
du sens et si ça n'a pas de sens si les
freins pas pour que un surdoué soit bien
dans sa vie bien dans sa peau
c'est important pour lui qu'il puisse
avoir la possibilité d'être plutôt dans
des rôles où ils soient leaders où il
soit ça soit lui qui conduisent les
autres qu'ils puissent avoir des
perspectives plutôt que de faire partie
d'une équipe